welcome back to games fest continuing
coverage of e3 2014 let me fix that
you're watching the game spot stage my
name is Daniel wire and I'm delighted to
be joined by my boy we've started every
single year I get to hang out with you
you and Activision cronies right Roy
here at the silent Roy who doesn't have
a headset so yes a whatever the goddamn
hell you want no we can't and we're here
with Skylanders trap team
Skylanders last year's swap force was
the big thing this year yeah y'all got
these crazy crystals that's right to
know what's going on what's going on we
have the the I love saying titular it's
my favorite thing the titular trap team
and basically the idea behind the game
is that whereas before we did you know
bringing a toy to life yeah taking a
Skylander bringing it in allowing you to
play as that skylander this year we're
reversing the magic and so we're doing
is we're on the tech flip it on its head
we're allowing you to find villains in
the game defeat them and then use this
new toy a trap yeah to grab them you'll
actually hear them get pulled out of the
game into the trap itself on the portal
and then once it's in here it's actually
written in here okay so this now has
become the villain that you just trapped
and you can play as them excellent and
so you can see we've brought a couple
that we've got pre-loaded this is one of
my favorites this is broccoli guy Brooke
is that is that the real name that is
the real name broccoli go ugly go that's
what happens when you've made like seven
dozen characters is it what are we gonna
call this one is regular go I just
broccoli dude I don't roughly guys my
favorites he's he's a life and so it's
cool that you can actually cast a
healing glyph and then switch back and
forth between that villain and your
Skylanders and so we're allowing you to
tag team between the villain that you've
trapped and you're skylander at any time
okay some really fun combination
gameplay excellence we're looking at the
game here can we can we go to the add
the handycam for a second because I want
to every time we do this a load of
Skylanders fans are in the chat and they
want to get like up close and personal
right yes explain a couple of these Bob
alright so what we have here we have a
new set of guest stars that we're
calling trap masters and you can tell
they're they're defined by the fact that
there
bigger toys better toys we've ever made
but all of them have this really cool
feature where they all have Crystal
weapons yeah and so they're called
trapped a Neum which is the the crystal
and you know element that we've invented
a potato trap taenia obtained 'i'm and
so we have here is we've got wildfire
who's got a trap teeny 'm heat shield
we've got jawbreaker with tritanium
fists we've got Crypt King with a giant
trap T Neum sword and we've got our
starter pack character this is snap shot
and he has a giant trapped a neom bow
and arrow
oh yeah like this guy yeah trapped ATM
is the is the hottest rare-earth metal
in the Skylanders universe that's right
and then in addition to the trap masters
we have brand new course knocking
everything over sorry what's 10 to 0 you
can make sure we hear that yeah yeah get
the speaker out of it and then so we
have some core Skylanders over here our
other starter pack character is food
fight and he's an artichoke with a
tomato launcher of course he is because
why not right hey this guy that's pretty
good he pairs really well with broccoli
guy yeah he means if you get the veggie
taskforce going it's got all those
tomatoes he's gonna go mess up his like
is his teachers have just gonna bring a
hand on it and then we have a chopper
who's a small dinosaur with a a
gyrocopter peridot suit jet pack you
guys are just you guys use like the
Wheel of Fortune style of character
creation is like what we got today
I mean jet pack and dinosaur I mean in a
way we can you know we have our own IP
everything's up to our imagination we
know what we'll play well
what looks cool what's gonna be fun
what's going to appeal to a kid is it
gonna be a little dinosaur wearing a
jetpack yeah it is today and if it plays
well it's great actually we've got a
torch over here George and she's a
blacksmith who uses her bellows as a
flame thrower hexohm which is pretty
sweet and then over here we actually
have oh I check her out and this is
beautiful over here and gear shift is
our our pre-order incentive that we have
in stores right now where if you
preorder the game
her day and date with the release of the
game in October but if you don't she
actually doesn't come out until 2015 all
you little teases get it now or get it
later
that's right stick her down there yeah
the rest of the team is there any
difference between the traps themselves
yeah so what you can see is that the
traps themselves like our Skylanders are
elementally aligned okay and so I have a
water trap I have a magic trap and so
you'll need to have the elemental a
light trap to capture that type of
villain okay yeah so this one we use to
trap chill bill a water troll who has a
freezer a and a frosty jetpack very good
I used to see you yeah it's mr. ice guy
yeah hey this thing doesn't work out I
can always yeah but you've been coming
right the puns for us it's great I mean
that's actually part of the fun is we
have so many puns at Hertz yeah and
right here here's another we have paint
Yatta
oh my god and paint me out of barfs
candy that's pretty good
and so his candy bar actually Dizzy's
enemies and then he is a giant sucker
which he can use to defeat them as well
how many characters are now in the
skyline is you know a lot so of course
we would swap forces around then you've
got multiple versions that know exactly
how does that stuff like kind of combine
with this now yeah portal work with all
the old guys yeah yeah and what's really
cool is the new game we actually have it
so that every single
Skylander that we've ever made q
completely works with Skylanders trap
team and so you've got all you know 250
plus swap force combinations you've got
all over a hundred and seventy-five you
know Skylanders toys that we've released
yeah you've got all the new guys and
you've got over 40 villains yeah but you
can find and trap in the game and any
combination of those can be tag-teamed
in between the create your own kind of
fun in the game excellent I want to
remind the folks at home if they want
any questions for Lou to send it to
Donnie O'Dwyer on Twitter make sure
they're passed over and last year when
they were here I said isn't it wonderful
how Disney infinity came along because
they obviously you know they saw what
you guys do is
maybe they'll have a cutter daddy today
we see min Tendo a banana MIMO which
kind of looks a lot of many miles from
Skylanders and what do you think when
you see like this space that you guys
kind of opened up and this toys to life
area you see all these other major
companies entering it is it a good thing
a bad thing is a flattering I mean yeah
it's definitely flattering I mean it's
one of those things where for us we've
you know created something so
captivating and it's just great to see
it grow you know it's great to see this
toys a live category become something
that's sticking something that kids are
really finding an affinity with
absolutely love it and you know for us
being the the kind of innovators of that
it's now our job to continue innovating
yeah continue leading the curve and to
keep coming up with something new and
unique and really I mean our entire job
that the way that we kind of define it
for us is we need to set create
something the kids see as magic
yeah you know I mean for you or me I
mean we see technology we want to be
like I wanna know how that works I want
to see the you know the bit since I
don't know the technology but but for us
in the office and for the you know the
kids at home what we're trying to do is
every year create something brand new
and every year create something that
actually appears you know as similar
understand as a magic trick and it makes
them feel like they're in power at home
yes it's like that thing we brought home
that really cool toy at Christmas and it
you knew the sound and made off by heart
and you knew every single aspect of the
model as well yeah it's like that well I
guess the videogame aspect to it as well
let's we've talked a lot about the
actual models themselves about the
portal and let's talk about the gameplay
is there anything new on the gameplay
slider you guys are bringing like there
it's a kind of a known quantity at this
stage to be not a good thing or bad
thing Skylanders games also exploration
interesting characters and stuff like
that are you doing anything new in trap
team in terms of the actual moments a
moment gameplay yes so I mean for us the
moment-to-moment is actually defined by
that tagging in of your villains and so
we're setting up a lot of different
scenarios where kids are using these
villains we've got Wolfgang on screen
right now you might actually enjoy it's
got a rock and roll werewolf which is
pretty fun has killer projectile notes
pretty good as guitar
does his 80s hair metal knee slide but I
mean for us that the combat is a major
thing and so what we've got is the
ability to switch back and forth between
your skylander and these villains and so
it's this constant combat question of
what do we do here you know who do I
want to use at that time and the way
that the villains work is that they
don't actually have health bars okay
they're on timers and so you bring them
in for a limited amount of time use them
you know specifically when you want to
and then they'll actually go back into
their trap in a resting state and you'll
have to wait until they refill before
you can use them again so it's really
trying to play up the interaction
between your skylander and the
villeneuve trap but then on top of that
I mean it's it's toys for Bob and
they're the guys developing it they're
the most creative team you know out
there and so for them they're actually
going through all these levels filling
it full of variety a lot of fun puzzles
a lot of fun interactions great
characters a tremendous story and a ton
of humor and that's really you know for
us bring something new and exciting
every year is great yeah excellent
that's that it's amazing that you guys
are able to keep making these games
where you have to bring all the old
characters back in again and lose
stutters thank you so much for coming in
and did you want to see the real quick
oh yeah real quick one here we go we
have an a3 exclusive trap people can get
traps even before the game is out oh my
god and we got hot exclusives dropping
right here in the camp on stage and it's
got a riot shield shredder who's an
exclusive villain you could only get
Eddie three sweet-looking I would make
it real it'd make it real hard for the
camera up just kind of yet depth
Internet of the devil perfect yet yes
it's got it good sweet are we gonna give
away a bunch of those on the GameSpot
Twitter account later on today so make
sure you're following their loose
stuttered absolute pleasure as ever to
see you Troy great job I hope you get
your voice back soon